yes we're all excited about Destiny's
next expansion rise of iron which
launches in September but it seems that
some images from an alleged equal have
leaked I'm Lucy and welcome to your man
another blue ingram gamespot news update
as discussed in this reddit thread in
our / destiny the game as these does met
off an artist who worked with bungie on
art for Destiny's last expansion the
taken King has posted art on an online
portfolio website for hands net that he
described as being from destiny to as
you can see it kind of looks like these
images could be from a trailer flipped
quickly between the last two they look
like video frames some of the first
images seem only vaguely destiny related
after all the first game doesn't have
that much to do with shields and swords
but you can clearly see in later images
the traveler hovering over earth and the
characters seem similar to Guardians but
it seems someone an activation caught on
as the artist page is now gone but you
can still see it with the help of a web
archive there's not much way to verify
these images without bungees input but
we have reached out to the studio for
comment and as for rise of iron the
expansion launches on sep tember 20th
for ps4 and xbox one so what do you make
of the supposedly are you ready for
destiny to or are you still completely
invested in the first game let me know
in the comments below or come by me on
Twitter I met Lucy James games for more
on destiny keep it gamespot
you